hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 22 of my 1 hour flipping
challenge today we're going to be doing
items under 100 GP uh which is actually
a really good suggestion uh from one of
my viewers so thank you very much for
that uh so any item that's under 100 GP
to buy the item is fair game I can sell
the items for whatever I want uh but the
Buy price has to be under 100 GP uh I'll
be interested to see if there's actually
any good margins available at this price
point cuz it's fairly cheap don't really
expect anything more than one or two G
on each item and we're going to start
with 10 mil and just see how it goes all
right let's get
started all right everybody we're about
to get started we have 1 hour on the
clock we're going to be flipping items
under 100 GP uh again these are going to
be under 100 GP for the Buy price I can
sell them for whatever I want but I have
to buy them for any price under 100 GP
all right let's
go so I had a bit of a strategy coming
into this and um I'm mainly going to be
using this high volume tab on G tracker
because it has a really useful uh filter
at the top uh which lets you filter Down
based on price uh buying quantity stuff
like that so I just put the maximum
price to be 100 coins uh put a minimum
buying quantity and there we go so we
got some recommended items also Clan
chat recommended some stuff
too I don't know about that one uh but
we'll go ahead and use some of those as
well probably uh so some of the best
items here I found uh when I just kind
kind briefly scanned it uh iron and
knives actually had a very good
margin so let's have a look at iron and
knives uh 73
into uh 71 so a little bit different now
but that's okay uh still 2 GP we'll go
ahead and do uh 7K I think is the limit
for that
one pretty sure it might actually stay
on here yeah look like at
7,000 and uh next up I was thinking of
doing the iron darts now they don't
trade as much as the knives do
but uh they're really cheap still
300,000 a day that mean that's not that
bad we'll go ahead and buy uh 10,000 of
those really doesn't cost us very much
money uh moving
on uh have a look at mythal
darts I'm pretty much going to try
anything that
uh doesn't have a one GP margin on it
cuz almost every item in the game has
one GP on it at least uh but just having
the one GP margin can lead to it taking
a long time to flip that item ow Dart is
pretty good too let's just have a look
at their buying quantity oh my God so
many trades
today and how much was the limit or how
much uh wow six GP on that that's insane
uh do 10,000 of
those now someone actually suggested
gold bars which luckily just sneak under
the 100 GP cost I'm pretty
sure uh bottom for 93 and 90 we do
that H 10K whatever now this is only one
GP margin so it's not
great but uh we'll probably put it in
there until we find a better
item still 10K not too bad I guess all
right salmon has a 5 GP margin on it as
well not too bad we'll have to see how
much cooked salmon actually comes in the
game and it's about the same uh so I
mean 10K salmon not too bad I guess uh
we have some mythal darts coming in
nothing else uh oh wait never mind we
got a ton of chaos
runes um yeah not bad all right I
remember doing bow strings quite a lot
uh they tended to have a two or three GP
margin than them and that did definitely
flip pretty quickly uh two GP on bow
strings we'll definitely do that and uh
10K bow strings looks like we have some
other stuff coming through as well uh
mainly the metal darts as well as the
chaos runes but uh other stuff is I
guess slowly buying
too so we just checked the steel Dart
tip it's 55 into 90 uh which is probably
incorrect uh because that would be a
little
crazy how many of these are traded per
day oh my God quite a lot so I guess
we'll we'll just do this and hope maybe
that we somehow get such a crazy margin
uh yeah we'll definitely might as well
take a risk on something like this all
right so we bought a 10,000 bow strings
and more uh we also got 10 or 5,000 of
the steel darts pretty much exactly and
um so we'll sell the blow strings off
quickly see if we can actually check it
again or if we kind of that up like
we always do pretty well um no we can
still sell them uh we bought the BL
rings for 888 kind of nice so we can
sell them for for 90 at least but oh
well whatever we're going to plop these
into cell uh we'll put them in for 89 uh
which is kind of a crazy
price but if we manag to sell that
that'd be quite a nice amount of profit
okay so guys we have sold off all the
steel Dart tips that is crazy uh we
definitely loed out there uh we haven't
bought a whole lot more I feel like we
most have got undercut uh so we pull out
the steel Dart tips that's a quite nice
amount of profit there we've sold off
the bow strings as well and uh cast
runes are selling bucket of sand
actually are buying pretty slowly
granted but they are buying mile darts
are buying we might plop those in the
cell now mythal darts seems like
ammunition might be the best call for
this uh under 100 challenge one for 40
pretty sure it was like a six or seven
uh margin on there plop them in here for
46 uh which is not terrible seem to
still be buying for
90 uh but now they're are selling for 90
but they're buying for 62 now uh still
pretty good margin on that so we'll
definitely do that still uh we'll just
uh bump that up a bit
more
63 and uh let's do 4700 just so we can
check it later all right adamant arrows
have a 1 GP margin on it I mean like
quite possible I could flip 10k of these
pretty quickly so we'll just do that uh
chaos Rune sold we got a 10K profit from
that uh actually we got some iron darts
buying uh which is pretty nice cuz they
did have a decent margin on those ones
and we got one more offer slot to fill
probably okay the steel Arrow has a 2gp
margin on it uh which will definitely
take advantage of assuming that's 10K as
well and we have one offer slot left to
mess around with or possibly pop in one
of these items to sell but we still have
40 minutes left so we might wait a
little longer okay we found another item
with a pretty large margin Snape grass
43 and 75 so uh once this loads you can
see snap grass actually trades almost a
million every day uh so we'll definitely
go ahead and buy some snap grass
hopefully we can keep that margin wow
okay so we sold all that Snape grass
already uh let's just have a quick look
at how much we probably made off that 24
- 44 * 3,000 that's
90k right there that's crazy even items
like this you can see actually can have
big margins if just so happens there
isn't any competition at the time for
the item uh you can get quite lucky uh
which is pretty nice I've never actually
experienced such a good margin on item
like that I've got some more snap grass
coming in and uh yeah all you have to do
is really cut off the items that aren't
working uh missile darts um not working
but you can see like we're still selling
steel darts we're getting look at look
at the margin like that's really really
good for the
prices um having a 30 G GB margin on an
item that's only 100 is very good okay
we've sold off all our snap grass again
and uh we' got not a whole lot more yet
we got 92 more uh but that's another 60
or 70k or something not bad at all we'll
probably just wait till we have a little
more snap grass before we dump the rest
in okay so we bought all the Snape grass
and we're in the process of selling the
rest of this pull that out sold a nice
amount of it already uh pop the rest in
for 74 since it sells quite quickly I'm
not even sure what the limit is on the
snap grass but obviously it's at least
10K and uh steel our tips uh we haven't
sold in a while just pull those up for
now uh that way we have just more offer
slots to mess around with and uh yeah we
still have 28 minutes left
maple long bows
unrung and bought them for 86 maybe we
can sell them for and not those
ones a decent profit
83 uh I don't know it's going to kind of
depend on the item if we think we could
actually there a long B and strung I
think so if we could actually sell those
in time I might consider
it uh actually 2 million 2 million a day
that's a fair amount uh just going to
undercut a little bit here maybe we can
get
10K yeah I mean we could do some oak
logs uh 3gp is pretty decent it just I
feel like I'm running out of time now
okay the unpowered orb must Trade A lot
it seems to have a 5 GP
margin uh yeah let's do the unpowered
orb and uh plop it in there okay it's a
3gp margin I that up a bit oh
well uh run out of ideas here so we'll
do 10,000 of those and uh really slowed
down a little bit now unfortunately we
have 1 2 three items not selling at all
okay so we bought all the owered orbs
that is uh pretty nice we're going to
pop them in there
for uh
208 I guess this'll be 20K in profit uh
not too shabby it' be kind of nice if we
get a little bit more on these I don't
know if there's enough time okay so we
have totally sold off nearly quite a few
things uh the buckets of sand we did
totally sell um steel arrows are nearly
sold Maple Longbow are nearly sold iron
darts are really almost sold and at this
point we're just going to wait for this
stuff to sell hopefully we can get all
sold in time these missile darts
definitely have dropped uh I think they
may have gone down to
38 uh that's that's based on nothing
really but uh that was their medium
price before I checked on G tracker uh
so we'll pop them there and see if they
sell otherwise we might take a loss on
them okay so we've sold off quite a few
more things we have about 7 minutes left
uh maple long bows all sold off I got
about 20K in there I think we got about
a 20K loss on these ones maybe more uh
steel arrows got a very marginal profit
on that uh iron darts are nearly all
sold all right guys uh we only have
about a minute left and we did
successfully sell all the s grass off uh
which is pretty nice iron darts uh we
have a couple left to sell any unpowered
orbs um unfortunately didn't sell at all
so we'll have to dump those for whatever
we can I'm very surprised how well we
actually did I this could have gone
either way could have been like 50k in
profit over the hour uh but I think
we're going to be closer to 3 or 400 uh
which is pretty good considering all
these items are under 100 GP they don't
have any margin really for the most part
we did find a couple good items mainly
the snap grass and uh oh I got more of
those in the inventory and the steel
Dart tips uh so really pretty impressed
with uh some of the items in this
category and it kind of just goes to
show that even if you don't have a lot
of money uh you can still end up with
some pretty good margins ow okay so
there we go uh timer's up we'll go ahead
and dump the rest of these items and
we'll see how much we actually managed
to make so we'll s the iron darts
quickly steel Dart tips quickly as well
maybe not so quickly uh unpowered orbs
where the bulk of our money is left here
for some reason all the actual prices
seem to be much lower than what their G
price seems to be it we're going to
put in for one GP okay we didn't get
screwed good and same with these ones
here iron Dart get rid of these okay so
we'll go ahead and claim all the
money all right so let's see how much we
made in 1 hour of flipping items under
100 GP in value we have made 534k in I
actually very happy with that that is
very good considering the price of the
items like I already said again the uh
snap grass by far the best item steel
Dart tips pretty good too and uh for
items like this I really think you just
need to find you need to find an a
popular undiscovered item and I know
it's kind of hard to do needs to be an
item that trades a lot but I might not
be having someone flipping it cuz you
can still get crazy margins like 30 GP
on an item that is cheap uh you just
have to find the right item all right
guys hope you enjoyed and and I will see
you guys in the next video
[Music]